in business just like in the world of
boxing
if you don't anticipate what the enemy
could do next guess what happens you
will be caught off guard and you know
what happens when we're caught off guard
we get knocked out you see whether you
had a phenomenal year in 2016 it was a
great your best income your etc etc or
you had a terrible year both of them are
liars because success makes you walk run
as if you're infamous nobody can touch
you you're untouchable you're amazing
all this other stuff so your guard tends
to come down your box like this when you
have failure you typically box like this
and you just keep getting kid because
you're timid you're afraid either way
either way the best way to avoid crisis
in 2017 is to anticipate crisis because
crisis hates going up against people who
fully know crisis is next move they
don't want to mess with people like that
be that person in 2017 you're gonna have
the best year of your life in business
family health in every possible way
if you anticipate